my problem was kind of hilarious i went
with a very good guy friend of mine
and another couple on a double date and
i actually
made out with the other guy's prom date
so technically my problem's pretty great
[Music]
i never got to have a problem this is my
first prom
i went with a good friend of mine who
was in school with and she and i used to
like
laugh constantly so we had a good time
and we matched we were both in like
black featuring red i definitely stood
out
i went to an all boy jesuit school in
miami
where i was closeted because in the 90s
that's what you did in high school my
prom was a lot of fun
i just remember me and my friends
renting a limo and we just
party from the time we got in the limo
to the time we got back
dropped off at home i had a good time it
was
definitely traditional we got like the
corsages what are they called
corsage oh i was prom king
i was very popular i was captain of my
cheerleading squad too i actually did
not attend prom
i didn't go because i didn't really feel
comfortable enough in my sexuality
or my gender expression to really go to
prom with someone who i'd like to go
with and what i wanted to wear
i went to prom with a close friend of
mine who ended up
dancing all night with a guy that she
liked and you know i had a good time but
i ended up
alone so prom i went with the girl
because it wasn't okay to be out
it was a great night but it wasn't a
night where i was where i was fully
i didn't go to prom i didn't go to prom
because
i knew i was a gay boy living in a very
southern city
so when i heard that buzzfeed was doing
a weird prom
i thought that was the most amazing
special thing on earth
[Music]
depending on where these kids are are
located their schools might not be open
to this kind of a thing and even if
their schools do have an open door
policy they might not feel comfortable
so this is a safe space tonight i think
that it's so important for queer kids to
see
other queer kids living authentically to
see all these young lgbtq
plus people together it really builds
community and i think that's something
that
lgbtq young people don't really get a
lot of i'm so
so happy to be like you know in
in this lifetime where we have
queer proms and we have pride in high
school it's just an amazing thing so i
love it
i just think it's important in general
to get together and just celebrate who
you are
it's so important to express
individuality absolutely and
togetherness at the same time especially
in
this political climate and it's so
unbelievable that one of the biggest
websites in the world buzzfeed
is putting on an event that's just like
completely inclusive
of queer kids and so all these people
around america and around the world are
seeing these videos and they're thinking
wow i'm not alone things like this are
happening when i grew up i didn't have
anything like this
i didn't have this kind of visibility to
to see and and to feel the support
there's like a box of like typical
problems so like to see something like
this would have been like
really cool like you would have had
ideas and like just not empowered to
like
show up to your problems wearing
whatever you want prom is usually like a
cisgender heteronormative
like tradition yeah times have changed
so much and it's beautiful to see kids
be able to celebrate who they are and
the fullness of who they are
the last thing you want to be thinking
about is are you allowed to go there
because
you choose to go with who you like you
love you know so i think it's important
to have events like this to raise
awareness that
this is something we're not going to
tolerate in the society that america is
better than this that people
are the same and equal
my queerest story oh so many girl
okay that's that's maybe a little too
dirty two years ago at the grammys
you wore like a full dress moment i did
wear a dress to the grammys
and it was bold and it was beautiful and
he got all raving reviews
i was once in a hug with ellen degeneres
and ellen page i don't know if it gets
any
weirder than that we're awesome i got to
open
britney spears circus tour that's pretty
major
so opening for kesha at my first bride
felt pretty queer and pretty amazing i
was
partially raised by a member of the lgbt
community
i'm straight but i've always kind of
been put in that box
i feel like i definitely connect and
understand
what the experience is honestly when i
started to get into glitter on my face
like in probably in the last like
year or actually a few months actually
oh i'm just all queer all the time i
mean i don't know if you could classify
one as being more queer than the other
i'm like a unicorn i mean you can't see
the horn it's invisible
you are not wrong period you're not
wrong and don't ever let anybody make
you feel wrong for just being you
keep resisting and keep uh being
yourself regardless of what people tell
you to do because society is really good
at saying oh be yourself oh wait but not
like that
enough of that [ __ ] be yourself and
shove it in people's faces if you're at
home
as a teenager dealing with bullying for
difficult people
i would say that it's important to stay
true to yourself the community is much
larger
than we think it is at times and i
remember growing up feeling like it's
this big
and once you kind of make these
connections it kind of opens that up
the people who matter don't care
and the people who care don't matter i
think if anybody's out there and they
feel like they don't belong at prom
prove all those kids wrong find a crew
to go with go with your friends go with
a with a date
i know it's hard and i know high school
makes it very difficult but
if you're at a dance it's your memory
it's not their memory
so do it for you you belong everywhere
and sometimes the prom
in some places isn't just the best place
for you but you can make that experience
somewhere else and it doesn't have to be
at the school or in the gym you have
something to give
you have something to offer as well it
definitely gets better and just try to
enjoy it and
i would say just be yourself like know
shameless for yourself
absolutely have fun and live your life
you only get one chance at this and you
have to do it your way
[Music]
you